which accent is the most intimidating
and the way we're gonna find that is by
reading a scene from Taken I don't know
who you are I don't know what you want
if you're looking for ransom I can tell
you I don't have money what I do if it's
very particular set of skills I feel
like my daughter go that would be the
end of it
I don't know what you want if you're
looking for ransom I can tell you I do
not have money that is bad
if you're looking for ransom I can tell
you hey I don't have any money
but I do have is a very particular set
of a skills if you let my daughter go
now that'll be end of this okay and
peace happy I love you whatever but if
you don't I will look for you find you
out of GPS and maybe kill you after but
I don't know I haven't decided thank you
whatever
hi guys on the other end just like